from the capital to the Cathedral in
Washington
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the United States now saluting their
41st husband as George Herbert Walker
Bush is brought with ruffles and
flourishes and a 21-gun salute from the
heart of Americans great democracy what
by the family the sons and daughter of
the late president as the ruffles and
flourishes take part and this great
building where so much of the politics
that the late president was responsible
for guiding took place as all the Bush
family salute
the car skip will be borne down the
great steps to the hearse that's waiting
and go from here to the Cathedral a
short distance about five miles from the
Capitol building a service will take
place
the tune holy God we praise thy name as
this great believer in the Episcopalian
Christian faith is brought down from the
steps of where he's been lying in state
in the rotunda at the center of this
great building led by the banner of
United States of America and followed by
the banner of the President of the
United States
[Music]
memories of a family for their father
and for a nation for their 41st
president and 43rd vice-president who
served in the Second World War and who
was very much a part of a generation in
politics that gradually is leaving the
world and the way in which business was
done and the honor amongst those who
were often at loggerheads or
disagreement is remembered and saluted
by the Chiefs of Staff who are present
here and also by Major General Howard
whose division is responsible for
organizing the great ceremonies of the
United States
as the Bush family watch service
representatives from the United States
Navy the United States Marine Corps the
United States Coast Guard the United
States Army and the United States Air
Force all in salute and carrying their
former president and commander-in-chief
the flag of the nation that the late
President George Herbert Walker Bush
served so fully not only throughout a
lifetime of service in politics but also
during the Second World War as a pilot
[Music]
at the service in the National Cathedral
in Washington the United Kingdom will be
represented on behalf of Her Majesty the
Queen by the Prince of Wales and all
over the world representative Tsar
coming here to look back at the four
years during which President George
Herbert Walker Bush was leading the
United States of America
[Music]
[Applause]
looking up at the great east steps of
the Capitol building ceremonial always
takes place for the inauguration of
presidents who lead up those stairs and
out to the balcony on the other side
looking down the Great Mall
the commander in chief has been saluted
the Barrow party will now travel to the
Cathedral where at four o'clock United
Kingdom time the service of the funeral
will begin but for now there is the
relocation of the family of the
political heads who have also stood here
with the bushes to salute the 41st
president and the hearse we'll make it
short